[Musique]
quelle était votre métier de rêve et un
petit mois tous mes copains dans la cour
de récré il voulait être shakira
rémoulade zinedine zidane il voulait
être bill gates
mais je vais vous faire une confidence
petit je voulais être présidente du
monde
très simplement c'était un moyen de
rencontrer plein de gens de passer son
temps à serrer des mains à faire la bise
et à voyager
pablo picasso disait chaque enfant est
un artiste mais le problème c'est de
rester artistes lorsque l'on grandit
alors j'espère avoir gardé cette naïveté
d'enfants certes aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas présidente du monde jeu désolé mais
j'ai osé rencontrer des gens et c'est
plutôt ça cet état d'esprit là que j'ai
envie de partager avec vous aujourd'hui
je suis entrepreneur de ma vie plutôt
que spectateur alors mon premier job ça
a été la rencontre
ces trois hommes ont eu un impact énorme
sur ma vie et pourtant je les ai
rencontrés sur internet alors est levé
la main est ce que à 21 ans
vous seriez prêt à partir en tour du
monde avec un inconnu rencontré sur
internet quelques mains ok tout commence
un 28 mars 2013 en chine lors d'une
soirée à refaire le monde avec des
copains je décide que j'ai envie de
partir voyager et tant qu'à faire autant
partir un tour du monde alors de retour
chez moi je tape bêtement sur google
tour du monde entrepreneur je contacte
les 50 premiers résultats et les
premiers à me répondre c'est eux
six mois plus tard je pars un tour du
monde avec edgar à la rencontre de
centaines d'entrepreneurs français à
l'étranger
l'idée étant de montrer qu'en fait des
entrepreneurs français ne fuit pas la
france mais ils la mettent en avant à
l'étranger tout ça à travers une
plateforme web
donc on passait trois à quatre semaines
par pays ont rencontré l'écosystème
on vivait avec des locaux ont mangé avec
des locaux et on faisait des vidéos dont
je suis parti en tour du monde avec un
inconnu pour faire un truc que je ne
savais pas faire des vidéos n'avaient
jamais fait de montages vidéo d'ailleurs
ça se voit à la première vidéo c'est une
catastrophe
j'ai mis un mois à la montée la
on a vécu des moments de dingue on a
vécu des moments magiques
on s est retrouvé dans un camp bédouins
en jordanie a skié un 15 août en
nouvelle zélande ou encore la marche je
suis charlie à rio mais en fait c'est
parce que je retiens de ce voyage on a
rencontré des gens heureux
des gens qui étaient passionnés dont la
passion qu'ils aient dans leurs yeux des
yeux qui pétillaient des entrepreneurs
c'est le cas de vincent et samuel ces
deux hommes étaient ont quitté leurs
jobs respectifs pour se lancer et
devenir faisait heures de chocolat au
vietnam pas une blague c'est un job qui
existent on peut devenir faisait heures
de chocolat ils ont vingt employés ils
ont une usine et ils vivent de leur
passion de l'art de faire du chocolat et
c'est ça que je retiendrai de voyages ou
encore de cette femme qui nous a dessiné
dans un burger à los angeles c'est edgar
et moi on peut le voir et c'est juste à
travers une rencontre un échange elle
est revenue en eau ayant dessiné sur du
ketchup
c'est ces moments là qu'on retient
peintres du monde c'est ces gens là
qu'on retient de voyage
alors aujourd'hui hors de retour en
france je retrouve mon cocon je retrouve
mes copains je retrouve ma famille et
c'est comment garder cette magie du
voyage
surtout que l'écosystème français
parisien on le connaissait pas du tout
on avait découvert une quinzaine d'entre
d'eux d'écosystèmes à l'étranger mais
celui de paris pas du tout alors j'ai
décidé de prendre un petit déjeuner avec
des inconnus deux fois par mois sont des
gens qui m'intéressent qui m'intrigue
que ce soit par leur vision par leur
passion ou par leur expérience sont des
gens que je trouve sur les réseaux
sociaux par mail à des conférences
d'ailleurs certains d'entre eux sont
même dans la salle aujourd'hui
concrètement comment ça se passe
je les contacte je leur fais un petit
mail un petit tweet si on veut et je
leur dis voilà votre parcours
m'intéresse
est ce qu'on peut se rencontrer souvent
on se rend compte de 8 heures à 9 heures
souvent dans le même café chez edgar
coïncidence je ne sais pas mais et on
échange on papote
donc oui il y a eu des files je me suis
fait planter
il ya des moments où c'est très gênant
au début on ne sait pas quoi se dire on
n'est pas encore fait réveiller mais il
ya surtout des moments où c'est
extraordinaire je sors de là j'arrive au
boulot il est 9h30
j'ai vécu un moment de dingue j'arrive
avec une patate mais c'est sensé
indescriptible littéralement
indescriptible et en fait c'est nous
mêmes qui nous mettons ces barrières
entre les gens on n'ose pas on se dit
que les blancs ça et c'est un moment de
silence voire gênant que on n'est pas
légitime qu'on n'a pas notre place là
vous pensez que c'est pas terrifiant
d'être ici près que j'ai pas eu des
doutes et en fait je n'avais pas eu
cette curiosité cette naïveté sur mon de
taper tour du monde entrepreneur sur
google je ne ferai absolument pas devant
vous aujourd'hui
alors rencontrer des gens c'est hyper
important aujourd'hui qui sont les
personnes qui vous inspire réfléchissez
y
on a tous un panthéon de personnes qu'on
admire des jeunes des moins jeunes des
personnes fictives des inventeurs les
politiciens des entrepreneurs des hommes
des femmes c'est qui ces personnes là je
vous demande pas de contacts et barack
obama par réseaux sociaux quoique son
équipe comme vous répondra sûrement mais
l'idée étant de tout le monde a été un
inconnu
à un moment donné alors comment est-ce
qu'on rentre en contact apprenez
rencontré aux et échanger avec eux est
ce que vous êtes déjà demandé quel sera
mon impact sur le monde quand je vais
mourir à mon échelle
comment est-ce que moi j'aurais
contribué moi ma petite existence qu
est-ce que moi j'aurais apporté de bien
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait dans ce
monde alors une amie appel en mars
dernier et me dit écoute lusage organise
un week end pour aider les réfugiés
autour de la technologie
c'est à côté de chez toi est ce que ça
te tente j'avais rien prévu ce week-end
là alors pourquoi pas je me suis
retrouvé dans un week end on a passé 48
heures avec des développeurs avec des
designers avec des profils business à
échanger à créer quelque chose à faire
des allers retours entre d'un côté les
réfugiés de l'autre les associations
comprendre leurs besoins
créer un début de produits et à la fin
d'un week-end intense
on s'est retrouvé avec le projet gagnant
donc aujourd'hui on lance avec une
équipe de sept personnes
une plateforme pour améliorer la
communication entre les associations et
les réfugiés
via l'envoi de textos centralisée alors
comment ça s'est fait de choses
un soupçon d'humains et un peu de
curiosité un peu de spontanéité
en fait contribué de manière
désintéressée aux et ses impacts et la
vie des autres mais c'est aussi et
surtout accepter de se laisser impact et
moi c'est cette expérience là qui m'a
construit qui construit mes valeurs qui
construit qui je suis qui construit tout
ça on connaît tous quelqu'un qui fait
quelque chose qui n'aiment pas tu te
réveilles le matin qui est pas content
d'aller au boulot alors comme beaucoup
de ma génération
j'avais pas envie de ça notre génération
et les différentes
on a le savoir à portée de clic on est
on a envie de créer on a envie de
réinventer le modèle on a envie de faire
changer les choses
d'ailleurs on nous appelle très souvent
les switcheurs à changer de job tous les
deux ans au bac
odyssée pardon on se dit que après le
bac ce sera différent en école
handicaperait l'école ça va changer
quand on a un job on se dit qu on
changera peut-être et pourquoi personne
ne le sait personne ne le sait à votre
place alors j'ai déjà me paye pas
j'ai sauté le pas aux juges créa boîte
avec ces deux hommes j'apprends de tous
les jours et pourtant je vous jure on
est si différent j'apprends deux parce
que l'entrepreneuriat aujourd'hui la
raison pour laquelle moi je me lance
dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est grâce aux
autres j'ai besoin d'eux on vit les
montagnes russes en permanence cdo qui
sont extraordinaires mais ces débats qui
sont aussi très dur heureusement qu'on
est plusieurs
mais l'entrepreneuriat comme la vidéo
l'était pour le tour du monde
c'est aussi un moyen et une excuse pour
rencontrer n'importe qui un truc de fou
n'importe qui devrait être entrepreneur
juste rien que pour ça pouvoir
rencontrer n'importe qui alors certes si
j'avais pas rencontré julien et robin je
serais sûrement pas entrepreneur
aujourd'hui mais aussi si je mettais pas
laisser porter si j'avais pas accepter
un petit peu de spontanéité et ce côté
imprévisible qui est risqué mais qui est
aussi justement très beau alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a lancé on a lancé
citron citron une intelligence
conversationnel qui recommande des lieux
c'est un robot avec qui on chat en fait
c'est un robot avec un zeste d'humains
vous voyez on y revient encore de
l'humain
il ya une question qu'on nous pose en
permanence alors ça marche et je sais
pas je ne sais pas si ça marche oui non
peut-être j'espère un jour chance
évident alors je veux un dictionnaire il
ya trois définitions à sa marche petit
un succès petit deux carrières de
l'emmener et petits trois jeux de cartes
solitaire pas tout à fait ma vision de
la réussite c'est hyper réducteur alors
j'ai demandé aux centaines
d'entrepreneurs qu'on a rencontré un
tour du monde
quel était leur vision de la réussite
chacun avait des visions complètement
différente pour certains c'était créer
de l'emploi
pour d'autres c'était réussir à en vivre
certains s'étaient chiffre d'un million
que ce soit un chiffre d'affaires que ce
soit en levée de fonds avoir un million
de clients pour d'autres c'était des
choses beaucoup plus simples comme
réussir à expliquer à ses grands-parents
ce qu'ont fait ou alors réussir à sortir
du lit tous les matins
en fait chacun a sa vision de la
réussite mais une chose est sûre la
réussite n'est pas un accident et
l'échec est souvent voire toujours dû à
un manque du mans alors citron est ce
que ça marche je sais pas ce que je sais
c'est que je m'éclate que j'apprends
plein de choses en permanence et en fait
ça me suffit aujourd'hui en tout cas ça
me suffit vous le reconnaissez donc on
en connaît tous un comme ça on connaît
tous incident savez le pari ce dans
l'âge de glace
quelqu'un qui dit demain je ferai ça
qu'il fait jamais demain je vais changer
de job mais qu'il fait pas quelqu'un qui
dit je rêve de rencontrer maintenant
mais qui l'a jamais fait alors faisons
en sorte de ne pas et sid et je ne
pointe pas merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]